hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the house now this is an
indie horror game that apparently has a
lot of different levels and it is kind
of on a day system hello how are you
you are furiously writing Oh finally I
have some peace mmm
I've rented this house I could escape
from work in my family we were driving
me crazy
and you renting this house was a good
idea although it is kind of creepy but
I'll get used to it I hope uh-huh
Barrett this amol couple lived here but
they moved out and put a really good
price on it so I guess I was kind of
lucky
wait did you rent it or buying it blue
did you rent it or buy it your story is
unraveling so this game is apparently oh
who could be visiting me at this
abandoned house that the owners probably
didn't die in of that I'm very sure oh
hello hi - [ __ ] [ __ ] hello oh no oh no
oh how do I move oh no what do i do wait
a minute
who's that okay I can't move
oh oh I'd click in ok oh Jesus I can't
move oh oh oh hey that's not cool
oh I look
[ __ ] oh my god okay oh oh
day two oh it's furiously right about
last night's experiences huh
we heard someone knocking on my door but
I figure it must be the winning uh-huh
my life will go the fried uh-huh
I have to find you and I guess for some
reason there is no phone or internet
service today and probably not some
deliverables how could get the fixed
sure I'm sure that's the way it went oh
I um I think I heard myself on that one
wow that like came out of nowhere that
is like the definition of jump-scare do
not do it again
I'm on guard now I've got my defense up
what is it that what is that what where
oh that I was looking more at the
mysterious flick shadow figure I see in
the doorway over there oh well what
happened to teddy bears eyes why'd you
have to take that away don't do it don't
do it [ __ ] you [ __ ] off and [ __ ] you you
dick I'm not getting out of bed you guys
see the blue thing down there don't you
yeah
okay nothing here it's gonna bother me
oh boy i'ma die Oh
okay oh no oh no oh god I'm dead dear
diary yesterday I died it was so fun
boy you think you'd leave there was
something weird going on last night I
had a nightmare and some creature
attacked me
but when I woke up the blood was still
on the window and on the floor I don't
know I think I might not be alone here
luckily electricity is back but the
phone service is still done if something
like this happened decided I'm leaving
what do you mean you just said something
attacked you I would be the [ __ ] out of
there
instantaneously you don't wait around
and if it comes back and bites my other
leg off boy I'm gonna be pissed then oh
boy what wait
oh I can move
what did I pick up what did I put it oh
yeah ah I can move now oh [ __ ] this
chair I got air you [ __ ] I'm so sick of
being on the receiving end of the
[ __ ] I will be the one who dicks
oh it was my suitcase alright then oh
good a secret passage
did I just level up was that a wife I
[ __ ] up I broke the game oh oh no I
think I slid and fell down what the [ __ ]
what the hell just happened
this game is why oh man hello HAP I
think it says HAP oh no I was horribly
wrong I can't read okay
where else are we going what else are
you gonna throw at me your game your
dirty game putting me in the dirty sewer
uh-huh someone speaking Parseltongue
down here is this a Chamber of Secrets
okay
straight ahead oh god there's gonna be a
giant worm or something at the end of
this I'm a dead man
radical Larry's gonna come bolting out
from the wall hello not I'm going
straight up never mind it's curving yes
is that previously suspected oh wait
[ __ ] ah there we go got to reload my
battery like a gun magazine that's how
it always works God where's this going
can I run oh I can run I was wasting
everybody's time and my own oh [ __ ] yeah
well I went the wrong way you can't
exactly blame me cuz I have no [ __ ]
clue where everything is dang it I'm
gonna run out of battery and then I'm
just gonna be in pitch blackness and
then probably hopefully it gets me dead
and then I can restart because otherwise
I'm boned I'm gonna be super boned
here we go incoming darkness Oh God the
demons demons are coming around I really
am barber Nook darn high because I'm
hey hey ah you are dead your organs got
squeezed can n explode it out of your
abdomen okay so let's try this again
but a little less stupidly so I can't
even leave my own doorway I gotta go
down [ __ ]
wha should it happen again okay so I
think I think I was going the right way
I think I was going the right way it's
gonna be like vanish all over again I'm
never gonna find my way out of here
ever ever ever ever no [ __ ] another
juncture how I know oh hello wow what is
that okay
is this good this doesn't seem good with
the red and the glowy I'll give it a go
what is this I can't click this I like
to click things won't let me interrupt
with it
let me do a thing please pretty please
no damn and I just found a big glowy
thingy for no raisin can I let me oh I
didn't pick up any spare batteries [ __ ]
I'm I'm [ __ ]
yep I'm [ __ ] okay I'm [ __ ] if I hide
back here you'll never get me he'll
never get me never ever ever ever hello
I fine I'm brave I'm a brave man I'm a
brave boy
oh I peed myself
oh my blood I need that so I was onto
something I obviously went kind of the
right way
I didn't go completely the right way
because that red room wasn't where I was
supposed to be just yet I have a feeling
I'm supposed to get an item and then go
there it's frustrating though because it
was starting out so good and then it
tosses me in the sewers to wander around
it's like why why did I get tossed down
in the sewers just to wander around and
why were these sewers underneath this
house I mean this house was owned by a
lovely old couple what did they have a
need for a labyrinth of mazes I mean
that seems like a problematic scenario
for anybody but I don't know why
habit so whatever I'll just wander along
c'est la vie that a dead end no that's
not a dead end that's a dead end
that is not carry load he I don't know
what I did what I did I had the
flashlight was I supposed to shine it in
something I don't know it's all very
nondescript I'm gonna give this one more
go and if I can't get it it just seems
like it seems like I'm gonna be lost
down there
nah I don't see much potential oh whoa
whoa what is that what is that oh I'm
not supposed to look at that that's the
thing oh I found the man oh man what is
this hello hi oh I found the room of
blood oh good oh great oh geez what is
this oh hi how did you who is this the
happy room Zoey there's so many smiles
whoo okay well I found something woof
woof you do not look comfortable okay
maybe there's some some bad ohi's here
okay got some batteries it was very loud
and startled II batteries but I got it
okay oh come on you can't just give me
the happy room yeah so that thing is out
there that's something that we have
readily determined and I have a feeling
you're supposed to conserve your sprint
juice so that you can go farther when
it's chasing you and probably flash the
flashlight at it and that'll be the
thing that gets you safe okay so that's
bricked up where the hell else am i
suppo oh no no be gone demon
the gunman ah I'm fine
I'm dead okay so this seems a lot more
complicated than I would assume it to be
and a lot more challenging because
number one you got to manage your
resources in terms of your flashlight
battery and number two how can you avoid
that thing if as soon as it sees you it
starts chasing you faster than you can
sprint you can't sprint that long to
begin with like what are you even
looking for so it's not very obvious so
if you want me to finish this let me
know what to do down in the comments
below I'll need your help with this one
and I'll probably need to look up a
guide or something but it seems a
potential but it had more potential in
the beginning than it did at the end it
was more interesting game in those first
few days than it was in the sewer I will
readily admit like I'm not wanting to be
too harsh on this I'm just saying what
it was it really was interesting in
those first few days so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought this game down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye-bye